[Music]
hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and in this video
we will be talking about two of the most
powerful quirks in the world of boku no
hero 2 quirks that in many ways shaped
the hero society into what it is today
one of these quirks belongs to the
protagonist of the story is ooh kuma
Doria and of course it used to belong to
all might before he passed it on to Deku
the other belongs to the arch villain of
the series the mysterious mastermind
behind the league of villains and the
man Segarra he calls master this villain
goes by the name all-4-one which is a
name that he shares with his quark and
he was finally properly introduced in
season 3 of the anime this video will
explain the origins of both one for all
and all for one how the two are
connected to each other and what is the
true extent of their power I hope that
having all of that info here in one
place will be useful to you and if you
like this type of content you can let me
know by leaving a like if you happen to
be new feel free to subscribe and
Detroit smash that notification bell
this video will include some spoilers
from the manga although mostly just the
stuff that's going to be covered in
season 3 of the anime if you're cool
with that then let's get into it
let's start with one for all which is
the quirk that we know more about
because we've been learning about it
since the beginning of the story one for
all is an emitter type transferable
quirk that works at close range and it
was possessed by seven other people in
the past before being passed on from all
might too Deku the ninth and current
user in order to transfer the quirk the
current user must give it up willingly
and the transfer occurs once the new
user consumes something that contains
the DNA of the previous users such as
one of their hairs
once the quirk is transferred from one
person to another the one who transfers
it can still make use of some leftover
embers which is why all might can use
the power despite having already
transferred the quirk to
nevertheless the old user cannot keep
using the quirk forever and the leftover
embers will eventually be extinguished
although this process of losing the
power completely seems to be sporadic
and it appears to take some time
one for all gives its users superhuman
strength agility speed reflexes and
stamina the full extent of one Falls
power is still somewhat of a mystery
such as when Deku was able to break
through the control of hito shishun so
squirt during the tournament arc and
this happened because apparently the
previous users of one for all who are
now deceased were somehow able to awaken
inside of Deku and help him break
through Shin hos mind control this type
of thing was never fully explained so
again there are some mysteries - one for
all that we're still not aware of
despite its immense power one for all
has some drawbacks such as the fact that
until the quirk is mastered it will
cause serious damage to the user's body
but all mites power and strength
demonstrates them once the quirk is
mastered it becomes incredibly potent
and powerful all my tells us that to
activate one for all the user must
clench their buttocks and scream smash
within their heart which is easily one
of the best possible ways to activate a
super power in any work of fiction
because its stockpiles power one for all
seems to get more powerful as it is
passed on from one person to another
although this is not directly confirmed
yet we do know that none of the seven
users of one for all prior to all might
were able to take down the villain all
for one but once all might gets the
power he is able to defeat all for one
on two separate occasions which might
indicate that one for all gets stronger
with each new user and speaking of all
for one this mysterious arch villain is
actually the creator of the one for all
quark one for all is a unique quirk
because it is in fact a combination of
two different quirks a quirk that
stockpiles power and a quirk that allows
quirks to be willingly transferred from
one person to another and this leads us
to another quirk a quirk of
4:1 all-4-one allows it
user to steal the quirks of others and
then use them himself and this includes
combining multiple quirks at once to
create incredibly destructive attacks
not only that but all for one also
allows its user to transfer stolen
quirks on to other people many
generations ago there were two brothers
the older brother was the villain known
as all-4-one and the younger brother was
a timid man who was believed to have
been born querulous because everyone
thought that the younger brother had no
quirk
all-4-one decided to transfer a quirk
that stockpiles power into his younger
brother
however the younger brother did have a
hidden quirk that never manifested so he
was not aware of it but this quirk
allowed him to willingly transfer his
squirt from himself onto someone else
this is how the quirk one-for-all was
created it is a combination of the
stockpiling quirk that all-4-one
transferred into his younger brother and
the younger brothers hidden quirk that
gives him the ability to pass his quirk
on to others the older brother
all-4-one eventually became the most
powerful villain in Japan and the
younger brother decided that he had to
fight against his brother's evil plans
he was not able to defeat all four one
on his own but he transferred his work
to the next generation and this process
continued for what we assume was decades
until finally all might the eighth user
of one for all was able to defeat all
for one at least for now because of its
ability to steal the quirks of others
all for one is one of the most dangerous
quirks in the world of boku no hero some
of the individuals who have had their
quirks stolen by the quirk known as
all-4-one are left in a vegetative state
similar to a coma and some who receive
stolen works from all-4-one are unable
to handle them and they turn into
mindless creatures however it is
possible for someone who had their quirk
stolen by all-4-one to recover and lead
a normal life
without their quirk and this was
demonstrated by wild wild pussycat
member ragdolls ability to recover after
losing her quark to all-4-one but if
stealing quirks wasn't enough the user
of all for one can combine multiple
stolen quirks in one person in order to
create more powerful super works that
would never have occurred naturally just
imagine using all for one to create
armies of super soldiers with
artificially engineered quirks which are
more powerful than any naturally
occurring quirks could ever be because
of its versatile abilities all-4-one is
definitely one of the most dangerous and
overpowered quirks in the world of boku
no hero
the names one for all and all for one
are likely a reference to the three
musketeers whose model was one for all
all for one referring to their sense of
unity although this phrase has been in
use even before the three musketeers
novel was published but in the context
of boku no hero there is additional
meaning to these two names one for all
refers to the fact that one quirk can be
passed on to multiple people and the
goal of this quirk is to help others
all-4-one refers to the fact that
multiple quirks can be stolen and united
into one person and that person can then
use them for their own ends the villain
known as all-4-one the user of all-4-one
had used his quirk to become the most
powerful villain in all of japan until
he was finally defeated by all might the
eighth user of one for all in this sense
these two quirks are not only some of
the most powerful quirks in existence
they are also quirks that in many ways
shaped the current hero society
all-4-one became a criminal mastermind
and created a powerful underworld that
controlled many aspects of Japanese
society for decades and posed a major
threat to the world
however all-4-one also accidentally
created one for all the quirk that
eventually led to his defeat all might
the eighth user of one for all became
the symbol of peace the embodiment of
justice and stability in the aftermath
of the chaos that all-4-one created in
the past all might emerged as the symbol
of peace because society was crying out
for someone to give them hope and
salvation after dangerous criminals like
all-4-one threatened to plunge the world
into chaos
but as Almighty brought about stability
as the symbol of peace
others like shigaraki came to see the
modern hero society and a symbol of
peace as fake and dishonest people like
shigaraki want to expose the values and
ideas of justice in modern society as
false and shigaraki thinks that the best
way to do this is to erode public trust
and heroes and especially in all mine in
Chapter 92 of the manga all-4-one tells
all might that shigaraki has been
working on eroding public trust in
heroes for quite a while
essentially trying to destroy the idea
of the symbol of peace so we see that
not only has the struggle between one
for all and all for one shaped the hero
society into what it is today but it
continues to shape it as new heroes and
villains emerge out of the shadows of
all for one and all mine on the one hand
Deku is all might successor and he has
inherited one for all and on the other
hand all for one has been looking for a
new quark to give to Shigure Aki whom he
considers to be his successor so we can
see that even the next generation of
villains and heroes is directly
influenced by these two works one for
all and all for one I think that this
creates a fascinating dynamic a really
interesting duality and I'm excited to
see how this conflict will continue to
play out in the future let me know what
you guys think which quark would you
rather have all for one or one for all
and which quark do you think will
ultimately prevail give me your thoughts
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more videos
like it be sure to leave a like to let
me know if you happen to be new to this
channel don't forget to subscribe and
Detroit smash that notification bell and
if you want to give us ideas for future
videos feel free to follow us on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you for all your feedback on
social media and in the comments and
until next time see us space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]